[Music]
so my name is Corrine Bhatia I'm a
Solutions Architect with with Google and
I lead our efforts around scientific
computing so and I'm here with a
distinguished a set of panelists mateo
Achin Ozzie Salvador Dora Bernal Ben
torque Ian Paul Saguna and what we have
for you today is a panel session about
how people are leveraging Google cloud
for doing scientific computing and for a
research computing it's really a great
time for for scientific computing it's
it's really exciting to be a
computational scientist today the access
to new processors new accelerators and
new software frameworks are really
enabling the researchers to harness a
large amount of compute capability and
really putting it at their fingertips to
advance science Google Cloud has a is
worldwide system we have built it on a
global network that includes everything
from the fiber optic cables to the
servers to data storage we have 17
regions distributed around the world we
have thousands of point of presence
sites undersea cables and submarines and
yes we have sharks that bite out of you
might have heard that we have sharks
that bite the fiber-optic cables and we
have to go down and fix it so all of
that is owned by by by Google and those
that capability with 17 regions around
the world is really made available to
everybody including the academic
research community so some of the things
that we do for the for the the
scientific community so the first thing
yeah is that we have a pretty robust set
a free tier of service
for for our products so not only do you
get when you sign up you get a I think
about a three hundred dollars in credits
to use generally but most of the
products themselves have a free tier so
for example if you're using bigquery you
can use a certain amount of bigquery
every single month a certain amount of
gke and other services every service has
a three tier and that's a great way of
exploring and using and learning about
the Google cloud platform for your for
your research if you need more than that
we have a research credits program where
we would we can provide you know some
more credits for you to leverage Google
cloud for your for your research needs
and we're working very extensively with
the funding agencies to make it really
easy to to allow you to get funding for
get Google cloud credits for your
research your multi-year research your
research projects we've had a really
strong collaboration with the National
Science Foundation and we continue that
with building more programs and more
interactions there and earlier this week
we announced a collaboration with a
partnership with the National Institutes
of Health as well so across the board
we're we're really making it as easy as
possible for scientific and research
computing to to be done with with with
Google Cloud and to show you guys what
people have done with this please well I
mean before we bring the the speakers up
there was one more thing there's a
National Science Foundation report that
just came out that that talked to this
but there was a workshop in January that
brought together a lot of academics this
was run by Jennifer Rexford in Princeton
University and it talked about how how
do facilitate Google Cloud for academic
use and why to do that so there's a
number of recommendations there within
that report for universities and for
academic departments and I encourage you
guys to to
take a look at that so please join join
me in welcoming Matteo to talk about his
research and how he's leveraging the
Google cloud for his for his science
hello everybody
Thank You Karan for the introduction and
it's great to be here so I would like to
start my presentation off by asking you
one simple question what would you do if
somebody came to you and asked you to
model mosquito bites well that was our
task back in 2016 and in this
presentation I'm going to tell you how
we developed a model with the help of
GCP to study the diffusion of Zika virus
across the globe and just to give you
some context so back in 2015 Brazil had
notified the World Health Organization
that the new mysterious virus was
circulating in the country a few months
later that virus was recognized to be
Zika and moreover during the same er
they also noticed an unusual increase in
the number of microcephaly cases in the
country and for the ones of you that are
not familiar with microcephaly
it is a rare neurological condition in
which kids infants heads are
significantly smaller than the ones of
other kids of the same age and sex it
imagine it may cause not only physical
but also learning disabilities as
newborns grow so because of this there
was soon suspected that they need a link
existed between the appearance of Zika
virus in Brazil and microcephaly and
other congenital and neurological
conditions and for this reason the w-h-o
declared in February 2016 a public
health emergency of international
concern and that's actually why we
decided to start working to this project
so our goal was essentially to try to
develop a model that could help Public
Health officials to better understand
the evolution in the dynamic of the Zika
outbreak across the world and by the
time we were done not only we have done
just that but actually we have developed
a new platform a new framework that
could allow us to study also other
diseases as I will tell you later on at
the end of this presentation
so now let me tell you how we did it in
the next few minutes I'm going to talk
to you about three things first I'm
going to tell you what were the
scientific and computational challenges
that we faced and how we overcame them
then I'm going to tell you what are the
main lessons that we learned while using
GCP in our journey and at the end I will
give you a taste of the kind of
scientific results that we can obtain
using our model but before diving into
the scientific challenges let me take a
step back and give you a piece of good
news so luckily for us at our labs and
thanks also to our network of
collaborators we have access to a team
of experts that know how to model
contagious the outbreaks and
particularly at mops lab we have a long
experience in modeling anything from the
seasonal blue flu to Ebola and actually
one of the things that we do best is to
develop computational analytical models
to study the spatial spread of diseases
and at the core at the foundation of
many of our work projects we have clean
which is our global epidemic and
mobility model that essentially allows
us to simulate and track the evolution
of an epidemic across the world from
beginning to end so let me just spend
one minute telling you how gleam works
gleam essentially is a piece of software
that allows you to combine different
data sources high-resolution census data
mobility data in complex disease
dynamics into unified framework and the
way it works is that it makes use of
this high-resolution population data to
divide the world into different
subpopulations which are then connected
to each other through a mobility network
that for example take into account for
the fact that people daily commute to go
to work or take airplanes to travel and
then what the model does is that it
takes each sub population and simulate
the diffusion of a virus within that
subpopulation while taking into account
for all the possible interconnections
that exist between them because of the
mobility network so essentially what
glim allows us to do is to simulate the
evolution of an epidemic at the global
scale unfortunately though for us when
we started this project there was one
thing that Glynn was not able to do and
that was model mosquito bites so the
first thing that we had to do was to
introduce first of all a mathematical
model that could allow us to model
mosquitoes within claim and second we
had to introduce additional data sources
within the computational framework of we
of gleamed actually to indeed model
mosquito presence and batting patterns
and the reason why we had to do that is
because the main drivers of Zika
transmissions are infected mosquitoes
that by biting individuals inject the
virus within a population and then those
same individuals in turn when they are
bitten by otherwise healthy mosquitoes
that can help propagate the virus back
to them back to the mosquitoes and then
the cycle goes goes on so however not
only we had to as I said at the new
mathematical model we didn't clean but
we also had to add new data sources
together with the population and
mobility data we already had to account
for different things the first one is
that we had to introduce very detailed
mosquito maps telling us where around
the world there are mosquitoes that are
able to actually carry Zika virus then
we all said to add monthly varying
temperature data to actually model
mosquito life cycles so mosquito lives
and deaths and then on top of that we
also to add socio-economic indicators to
account for the fact that if you live in
an area where you have access to better
sanitation facilities or simply there is
more widespread use of air conditioning
then you are less subject to be bitten
by a mosquito and therefore of
contracting Zika after we have done all
of this however all of this however we
were not done because there were other
challenges that we had to face first and
foremost we did not know the new
original time and place on introduction
of Zika virus in Brazil and that
essentially meant that we didn't know
from where and when to start our
simulations from plus since now we have
additional complexity in our model we
have many more additional parameters
that we need to calibrate because not
only we have to trace and stimulate
people movements but also
mosquito presence and batting patterns
and obviously since it was the first
time we were doing something like this
we also would like to have a
computational framework and pipeline
that will allow us to have quick
iterations between different versions of
our model so all those problems actually
translate pretty direct
in some very specific computational
challenges that we had to address the
first one is that since we didn't we did
not know the original time of
introduction of the virus in Brazil we
had to run longer simulations we gleamed
to essentially explore back in the past
what was going on and that meant that
each single simulation of a global
epidemic will take up to seven minutes
on average to run however because of the
randomness that we have in the
complexity that we have in the model we
actually have to run 200,000 of those
simulations to have robust results and
that unfortunately for us generates
about 25 terabytes of data that then we
have to process and as I said we would
like to do all of these around the
simulations and analyze the results
quickly meaning in the survey and that's
essentially where DCP came in to save
the day and help us with our research so
what is the cloud-based solution that we
devised to address those challenges
first of all our first stop was actually
to deploy a gleam on compute engine to
essentially help us scale up in terms of
a number of parallel jobs we could run
at the same time and to give an idea
that meant at a peak research hours we
were using up to 30,000 cores at the
time moreover since we did not want to
actually saturate our own Prem and FS
partitions we decided to store from the
very beginning all our data raw data on
cloud storage and to use the power of
bigquery to actually parse all those
terabytes of data that we were
generating to add essentially all our
simulations done and analysis within a
day and then our pipeline will close
essentially moving back all the
processed data to our local machines
where we will generate then the figures
in the numbers we wanted to look at to
analyze what happened with our
simulations but let me give you some
numbers to get an understanding of the
scale of our efforts so overall we
simulated more than 10 million global
epidemics from beginning to end and that
amounted to about 2 more actually than
250 compute years and to run all those
simulations we deployed more than
450,000 instances on the compute engine
and analyzed more than 300 terabytes of
data on bigquery
while doing this will we learn few
things
first off we learned that in order to
save money actually was better to move
from standard VMS to pre empty balls
because that essentially allowed us to
run five simulations for the price of
one and to profile in so to profile our
software for example in terms of memory
usage to then allow us to use custom
machines instead of regular instances
and in terms of time saving what we
found was that it was extremely
beneficial to actually run many
concurrent job loading job in bigquery
to drastically reduce the amount of time
we had to wait to actually populate the
database with all the terabytes of data
that we were generating and last but not
least we automatized our entire pipeline
using the GCP client library for python
to allow us essentially to run all the
simulations plus all the analysis and
get the very end a very nice PDF report
with all the numbers and figures we
wanted to look at without new without
human interventions so now let me give
you a taste of the kind of results and
the kind of things we can do with this
so first of all we can use gleam as our
own personal time machine to go back in
the past and try to figure out what was
the original time and place of
introduction of the virus in Brazil and
for example what you see there is that
we find that the most probable time of
introduction was between September 2013
and February 2014 but of course what we
can do is that we can also peek into the
future so what we can do for example is
to generate very detailed maps for a
specific time period telling us how many
Zika infections there were in specific
places in the world and we can also
since we are tracking traveling within
our simulations account for how many new
cases of Zika are imported because of
our traveling to different countries and
then compare those data with the ones
that are actually observed and collected
by local authorities like for example
the CDC in this case so what's next for
us well as I told you at the beginning
our platform now can of course model
Zika virus but in principle can be used
and extended to study also other of
ektron birth diseases for example dengue
yellow fever and chikungunya therefore
please stay tuned to hear more from us
in the future regarding this but if in
the meantime you want to know more about
all our other projects and oldham
people that actually worked on this
project please have a look at our
website where you can find more
information about this project and all
the other amazing things we have been
doing and thank you for your attention I
want to leave the flow to Salvador to
tell you about how you can simulate the
brain with DCP thank you hi everyone so
I want to start by quoting President
Obama two years ago he was surprised
that as human beings we were able to
understand particle subatomic particles
we were able to understand galaxies
light-years away but we were still
unable to understand the brain the
mysteries of the brain that three pounds
of matter between our ears which is
basically responsible for everything
that we experience and everything that
we do he knew that the this knowledge
could be transformative so he decided to
start a massive project research project
called the brain initiative which is
over four billion dollars to try to
understand the brain many other
countries in the world have done similar
things and that's why understanding the
brain is now considered the new space
race so today I want to talk about three
things first why study the brain why is
it important how we can use simulations
to understand the brain and how we will
cloud help to run these simulations so
why study the brain the main motivation
for me was knowing that one out of six
people suffers a brain disorder this
range from depression anxiety
Parkinson's epilepsy schizophrenia so
this means that if you count five people
in your row one of you is likely to have
one of these disorders as an example I
want to show you what we can do to help
with these disorders so I'm gonna show
you a video from CBS 60 minutes magazine
which shows a woman who's paralyzed from
neck downwards so she cannot move
any part of her body but she has an
electrode implanted in her brain
so with this electrode we can read the
signals of the motor cortex which
controls the movements and then she is
able to move an arm almost as if she
wasn't paralyzed there's no sound but
she's basically explained that she can
move the arm up and down she can close
the fist open the fist and she can now
even try to shake the hand of the
presenter
the presenter is pretty amazed that this
can happen and now she offers to do a
fist bump so this is obviously pretty
amazing and the reason this can happen
is that we actually understand how some
of the signals in the brain are encoded
and we can use that information to
decode them but of course there are many
things that we can do now to improve
this as you saw the movements are not
yet very fluent very smooth so there's
many things that we can do to understand
the brain better so how do simulations
help understanding the brain first I
want to start explain why the brain is
so complex to understand and the reason
is that there are many levels which are
nested inside each other so this could
be like an analogy to nested Russian
dolls so if you start from the higher
level you see that this outer layer
called the cortex is sort of if you
stretch it out it would be like the size
of a pizza and it has many different
regions which have different functions
so for example to process vision to move
your body so if you go and zooming into
one of these regions what you see is a
very complex circuit of neurons they are
also structured in different layers
there are six layers of neurons and they
process all the information and code
what you're doing and if you go even and
zooming into one of these single neurons
you would see that the this is also a
very complex machine so it has lots of
chemical process processes going on lots
of electrical activity and what's
interesting and complicated is that
these three different levels interact
with each other
so if you want to test something at the
molecular level so you for example try
and until the present drug and anti
poletik drug caffeine you have to check
what happens at the single cell single
neuron level that's going to affect the
circuit level then in turn the whole
brain oscillations for example and
finally the behavior of the human being
so how can we make sense of all these
complexity so luckily for us there
there's been many years now of
experiments done on the brain
both measuring the shape of neurons
how they're connected the function of
the neurons and what we can do it
simulation is try to put all this
together so here's an example of a
simulation based on lots of experimental
data from many years and what we do is
reproduce as accurately as possible the
experimental data that we have and then
we can use these models which are very
similar to the real brain to test
experiment with for example new
treatments to treat some of these
disorders that we saw that Vantage of
having a simulation is basically that
you can test as many combinations as you
need so in the real brain is very hard
to test different treatments because of
ethics reasons so in the simulation you
can do thousands of different tests with
different parameters different
combinations so I'm going to show you an
example of some of the modeling that I
do it's Center in the motor cortex the
part of the brain that controls movement
and here I'm showing the basic level so
this is a single neuron from the motor
cortex and it's important to model very
accurately the single neurons because
they are basically the building blocks
of the brain so a single neuron can be
responsible for our perception can be
responsive responsible for moving an arm
they integrate information from lots of
other neurons and then perform functions
the shape is a very important aspect so
if you have the wrong shape in a neuron
for example less branches that could
lead to disorders like Alzheimer's or if
you have a neuron that responds too much
electrically that could lead to epilepsy
so it's important to model very
accurately both the shape as we we see
here on the Left we have the
experimental data that's an image from
3d microscopy and then the simulation
which is very similar and also the
electrical response so we have the
experimental data and we have the
simulation which is again very similar
to the original so to simulate these
neurons we use a very detailed
mathematical model which implies
requires solving differential equations
hundreds of differential equations every
millisecond and it basically calculates
the currents and
voltages at every point of the neuron so
this was an example for a single neuron
but what I do is simulate a circuit so I
simile a tissue a brain tissue of around
the size of a grain of salt which
includes ten thousand moons who as
detailed as the one I showed before and
over 30 million connections so these
connections are based on experimental
data they depend on the cell type on the
layers were their position they have
inputs from other regions and using this
model we can now check how information
is processed encoded in these circuits
and we can also test all these different
drugs and treatments so as an example of
how much computing power this requires
one second of the simulation with 10,000
neurons and 30 million connections
requires around one hour in 50 cores of
the super computer so how did I use
Google cloud to simulate the brain so I
mentioned one of the simulations
required 50 course but of course we need
to run thousands of these simulations
why first because we need to optimize
the model to reproduce the real brain
biology so we have to run many parameter
combinations to check that our model
actually that's what they will bring to
us and secondly once we have a model
which is actually close to the real
brain we can use it to experiment with
it we can for example test all these
treatments test also electrical
stimulation treatments which is a new
type of method that is used to cure
disease and so we need to run thousands
of these simulations so as an example if
I wanted to run 1,000 of these one
second simulations I would require
50,000 core hours one hour in 50,000
cores so this is a massive amount of
computing power that is required and I
want to show you the evolution of how I
started using supercomputers we started
with a university cluster which had 500
cores and this very quickly showed it
was very limited we then used an NSF
scientific shared cluster with around
7,000 course
but it also turned out to be not enough
for our simulations and we have very
recently moved to Google cloud which
allows us to use up to 50,000 cores at
the moment but you can actually use more
and this translates is just as an
example to show you the amount of time
required to run this 1,000 brain
simulations so in the original
university cluster that would be over
120 hours in the scientific shirt
cluster it would be over 30 hours and in
Google Cloud I can just use one hour to
run all the simulations so this for me
means that I can speed up my research
enormous ly I can think of an idea a
treatment design the simulation and test
them in just one hour which is really
helpful for me so I just want to show
you some of the results illustrating
some of the results obtaining these
simulations so here we see in the
background a representation of the motor
cortex circuit and we see on the top
left the diffusion of calcium which is
one of the molecules used in synaptic
plasticity so it's involved in learning
in Alzheimer's and we can see how it
diffuses around the neuron we can also
see the electrical activity the spikes
of the neuron at the bottom which is the
way that neurons communicate and we can
see two measures of the statistics of
the statistics of how population's fire
and the oscillations of these
populations these are related for
example to things like epilepsy so what
are some of the advantages of using
Google cloud in particular compute
engines which is what I used as I
mentioned already
I have virtually unlimited number of
nodes that I can use and I have no
queues in most of the other
supercomputers there are queues of over
one or two days before the jobs actually
start start running the other advantage
is I can deploy fully customized
clusters so I can build the cluster to
my requirements specifically which makes
it very efficient and the cluster
importantly scales up automatically so
as
soon as I start submitting jobs new
notes start lighting up and once they
are the jobs finished they turn off so
that makes it very efficient and very
cost-effective it is also integrated
with these LARM workload manager which
allows you to submit jobs very easily it
allows to have several users connect to
the supercomputer and submit jobs and it
allowed me to reduce some of the code
the scripts that I had for previously
tools that I use using storm so I could
just deploy them and using use them
directly in Google Cloud finally I'm
also using taking advantage of these
preemptable nodes which are basically
four times cheaper the disadvantage is
that they get preempted so they they are
taken away around ten percent of the
time so to minimize the impact of
getting preempted we learned a couple of
tricks in particular if you balance the
duration of the simulation and the
number of course you use by using less
course you can minimize reduce the
chance of these nodes getting preempted
you can also run during the night which
is a simple trick and it means that less
of the jobs get preempted and you can
also generate script that automatically
resubmit that jobs so you don't have to
take into account whether some jobs
finish or not and they are just after
some time they will all be completed so
I just want to finish by concluding that
Google Cloud is basically helping us
understand and treat brain disorders as
I mentioned before this brain disorders
affect a large part of the population
and so there are many promising lines of
research now that are happening and this
space race for understanding the brain
is just beginning so I think we can all
look forward to very very exciting times
ahead thank you
[Applause]
and I want to pass to Ben who's gonna be
talking about investigating microbes
thank you hi everyone start my talk with
this code microbes run the world more
than more than half of the oxygen we are
breathing is generated by microbes more
than half of our body is microbe and
studying the microbial ecosystem are key
to our survival one of the method to
study microbial life is metagenomics
metagenomics we go and take a sample
from the environment and trying to
understand who is there and what they
are doing and this give us the snapshot
we can try to gather and understand the
what's happening in that environment and
our goal is to collect as many a
snapshot as possible to be able to
hopefully make a climate change model
and then we see how the microbial life
changing as climate changing because
that's going to be key for us in our
study we actually go to their island in
Bahamas called San Salvador and you can
see this islands are really unique
because they have many many ponds and
you can see their study pond the one we
are doing our work is marked with a red
arrow right there
they're unique because dark in close to
the ocean but they're close pond they
are not open to the water they go
through much rapid climate change
compared to any other environment that
enables us to observe the climate change
much faster and when we take a sample
they can have a better understanding how
the climate change affect our sample and
we're trying to kind of collect all this
information whenever we take it any
sample from this environment and I'm
sure saying Bahamas that's what you guys
thinking yes it's beautiful
you really have fun to go in there but
most time this is our view because these
ponds are so close to environment they
go to really harsh environment
in this pond ek see the salinity is
really high the water change yellow we
saw even purple or other colors depend
what happened to that environment the
color of water changing and that really
interests us to see what happened to do
is microbial ecosystem in that
environment and as mentioned we go there
literally trying to not disturb the
environment and trying to pick up the
sample then take the sample to our lab
trying to sequence it and run our
computation to understanding what's
going on in our sample but still be
dealing with two main issue one of them
are data getting bigger and bigger I'm
sure everybody here heard the sequencing
technology getting cheaper and cheaper
the sequencing our own DNA our dogs now
and beginning more and more data and we
dealing our experiments for each
snapshot like 10 terabyte of data for
the study of you're working on we have
10 a snapshot be dealing with hundred
terabyte of data to compute and that's a
lot of data to just go through also if
you guys know bioinformatics
genetics algorithm they are
computationally expensive everybody I'm
short hair about assembly or alignment
there have been lot of optimization to
these algorithm but still they are
heavily computationally expensive and
they're not much we can do but just
compute the data as as data get growing
the compute try and grow into what we
try to do we come back and look at our
workflow in a lab and we understand the
compute time and analytic part is the
main part we need to focus and trying to
solve the issue and that was we kind of
trying to go our University cluster and
see what we can do and change to our
workflow to be able to compute our data
much faster we come up with our own
workflow we design our own workflow to
be able to a scalable job but if your
family here with the workflows the
second you see this picture you should
recall this this is MapReduce what we
did we adopt a MapReduce model to our
workflow and you can see in the top you
can mention
the part we are doing to our work
workflow is in the top and and you can
see how it's matched to the MapReduce
and that was the reason we thought oh we
solved the issue now we can scale as
much we need but in reality when we
don't run our job we were really happy
to see the job was taking seven years to
change to three and a half months but if
you know research most times we have one
or two year if you get a live grant it's
five years and I mentioned we have ten a
snapshot in this case we're gonna be
around three months just computing the
data I don't know when we're gonna be
able to actually publish or do the work
that was the reason we kind of reach to
our friend at Google and ask them for
help and we estimate after we transition
to GCP we can finish the same work in 12
hours that's a big deal I'm gonna invite
here my friend Paul to tell you guys how
we move our work flow from our local
cluster to GCP thank you hello that's
right thanks man
yeah so as part of the HPC team at the
University our job is to help them
accelerate their research and if we see
that we can go from seven years to half
a day well we need to make that happen
so our first step was to come up with
plan we really wanted to deploy a
cluster in the cloud that happened to
look like our environment back home we
wanted to dynamically scale that
environment based on his job size or
future job sizes we also wanted to
dynamically install a software stack
based on the software he needed or
needed to change and so on we also had
to come up with the best storage
solution because we're dealing with a
lot of data and one mistake could cost
us a lot so next stage was doing small
test you know we needed to iterate
through the process to basically
optimize make sure that we're doing this
exactly right
again it could cost us we had to develop
tools to basically script au automated
job submission because of the large set
of jobs and samples that we had to work
with after we did that we're able to
scale up to smaller just to make sure
our scaling is working right before we
have to send out that big job
and then lastly that big job we have to
hit the Go button submit the entire
works out monitor and verify that these
results are coming back right so this is
what our solution ended up looking like
and you know you can kind of think of
this as our our input our compute and
our output now our input is our
reference database which is actually
going to be the same for every job that
we run and then of course our sample
database we ended up using an attached
persistent SSD for this entire run every
job had this attached persistent SAS SD
but the key was it was read-only this
worked extremely well for us it was fast
and scaled extremely well our compute so
our computers our dynamic HPC cluster
and as I said I wanted this to look like
our cluster back home so it does we have
a login node a controller node in our
compute stack our compute stack ended up
being the 32 core instances out there
now this is all managed with the slurm
workload manager so as mentioned in the
previous talk our jobs actually scaled
with with the cluster so it worked out
great our output so our outputs are
actually relatively small and you know
we didn't really need big scale SSDs big
big scale file storage we actually sent
our data at the end of our jobs to a
Google Cloud button bucket so the job we
ran on a hundred twenty four thousand
three hundred fifty two cores
concurrently we ran on three hundred
three thousand eight hundred eighty-six
nodes and we did that in 16 and a half
hours
so challenges and findings for our run
it was enormous ly successful I think we
had two instances where the note notes
didn't come up right we resubmitted
those jobs automatically through our
scheduler it worked great during the
testing phase as I mentioned we had to
find that best storage we tried and a
fests we tried the one of the elastic
file which was neat but kind of overkill
and tried some local disk options and
you know we ended up going with that
combination of the local SSD and
connected to that persistent SSD worked
great slurm so slurm was a lot of fun
you know we we use the slurm workload
manager back home on our cluster so we
are already very familiar working with
the Google team and the slurm team we
went through a lot of tweaking a lot of
making it just how we wanted lastly
something we didn't anticipate is
hyper-threading in our HPC space and in
most HPC shops we don't use
hyper-threading we it just doesn't
provide any advantage it's already
enabled in the cloud so that actually
affected our run time slightly so it's
just something for us to keep in mind in
the future so our take away and our key
next steps this greatly greatly enhanced
our research I mean it really made this
a reality for this lab our collaborative
process with the Google team and the
slurm sched MD team was fantastic you
know we provided feedback they provide
suggestions I think we actually led to
some code changes and updates and things
like that my my goal even before this
and then and still moving forward is us
to locally burst our environment into
cloud and this is exactly what it was so
we're really looking forward to the
future and now that this has been this
particular run has been a success for
this research lab that lab is now able
to seek further funding and able to
expand the research you know climate
change doesn't happen in a day
he needs samples for months years even
decades so he already has about a year's
worth of data ready to compute and if he
tried to continue what he was doing on
his local PC it would take him 50 years
just four years worth of data on our
cluster to 0.2 years and that's if I
actually let him on my cluster for 2.2
years dedicated GCP three and a half
days I'd like to thank Bob Dornan he's a
another member of our group that made
this project possible
Shawn Norman who is the lead pi4 the the
research and of course our Google team
[Music]